a king has his reign and then he dies
it's inevitable I've been so lucky this
past few years to work on some really
high-profile films the Avatar being one
of those that it's kind of odd that most
people on the planet know of it so it's
very excited to be a part of that and of
course JJ Abrams Star Trek the last Star
Trek and the current Star Trek that's in
the works super 8 Cloverfield I'm still
proud of Parana the work I did on
piranha 3d it's a good fish and there's
some TV shows worked on Terra Nova to
get a lot of the dinosaur work for Terra
Nova which you know there was a much
design necessarily invention because the
dinosaurs had to be realistic and
falling skies and we're doing a lot of
development now in terms of some TV and
some film work I've been working with
Ron Howard and Brian Grazer for the past
couple years doing development on a
variety of projects and some of those
are just now starting to get traction
yes is there I came on specifically to
do creature design I was going to do
some costume the spacesuits that they're
wearing but that quickly went to the
costume department as it should and I
focused all my attention really on
creature but the first project was the
engineer and that was like a real tough
nut to crack because Ridley had a very
specific idea and you know when you look
at that as a creature it's very much a
human being so in terms of designing it
you're not really stretching the
envelope it's about the specifics of a
cheek a nose you're basically designing
a human being but one that is classical
Roman Grecian God light in our
perception of Greek gods which is an
interesting parameter when when Brittany
first asked me to be involved with the
engineer he was very specific about what
he wanted it to look like in terms of
metaphors and I was looking at reference
of Statue of Liberty the Michelangelo's
sculptures specifically David and oddly
Elvis Presley I did look at all of those
and it was really interesting because it
was all about the profile all about the
nose and the three of them had very
similar looks and it really clearly
studied all three and he said that is
the feel that I want this to have it in
the end you don't look at it and go you
know that looks like Elvis
I don't think I hope big things have
small beginnings it was an incredibly
talented team that I've worked with
before on other films so these these
guys established the look of the world
and for Ridley that was a different way
of working to have it completed so he
said that is how I want to do Blade
Runner and I want you to be involved if
you're available so what does one say to
that